Ein paar Kilos müssen noch weg.
Training in der Schweiz.
Hier im Wallis bin ich aufgewachsen,
auf 2'000 m Höhe.
Ich sage gern: "Ich bin ein Bergler."
Nur: Ich stand auf keinem der
berühmten Gipfel in meiner Heimat.
Vom Bergsteigen
habe ich keine Ahnung.
Doch einen grossen Wunsch hatte ich
während meiner
zehnjährigen Korrespondentenzeit:
den Elbrus in Russland zu besteigen,
den höchsten Gipfel Europas.
(Frau) Du weisst,
was auf dich zukommt?
Eine Herausforderung,
eine körperliche v.a.
Zehn Jahre Korrespondentenleben
sind nicht gerade das Beste
für die Fitness.
Dann wurde ich noch zweimal Vater,
wobei ich nicht den Kindern
die Schuld geben will,
aber das ist immer
eine gute Ausrede.
Nein, es ist klar.
Was man nicht weiss, worüber man
nur liest, ist das mit der Höhe.
Ich war noch nie auf 5'000 m ü.M.
Ich kann nicht sagen, wie das geht,
aber der Wille und das Durchbeissen,
das ist eine Ehrensache.
Also von dem her ...
Ehrensache auch deshalb,
weil der Erstbesteiger des Elbrus
vor 150 Jahren ein Walliser war.
Und nun will also auch ich,
der Anfänger,
den 5'642 m hohen Vulkan erklimmen.
Mein russischer Bergführer
Alexej Schustrow und mein Team
erwarten mich bereits.
Guten Tag.
Herzlich willkommen, sehr angenehm.
Mir auch.
Mein Schicksal in Ihren Händen.
Lauter erfahrene Bergsteiger
begleiten mich auf meinem Abenteuer.
Victor hat um die 40
Elbrus-Besteigungen in den Beinen.
Und auch mein Kamerateam und
meine Regisseurin sind bergerprobt.
Alexej Schustrow
kommt aus St. Petersburg.
Seit mehr als 25 Jahren
führt er Menschen aus aller Welt
auf die russischen Berge.
Ah, Sie sprechen auch Französisch.
Ja.
Ich habe etwas Rückenschmerzen.
Vor zwei Tagen
war ich bei einer Physiotherapeutin.
Sie hat mir gesagt, ich solle hier
jemanden finden und dranbleiben.
Es gibt hier
einen sehr guten Masseur. - Ja?
Wenn die Leuten zu ihm gehen,
sind sie zufrieden.
Okay. Hier im Hotel?
- Ja, hier.
Wie viele Kilos?
Die überflüssigen?
Nein, insgesamt.
Es waren 104, jetzt sind es 100 kg.
Ich wiege 107.
Einatmen. Und ausatmen, entspannen.
Entspannen.
Die Arme hinter den Kopf.
Noch einmal einatmen.
Und entspannen, ausatmen.
Hast du keine Angst,
dass etwas kaputtgeht?
Nein, ich habe gemerkt,
das hat mir gut getan.
Das Problem liegt im Kreuzbereich.
Aber die Beweglichkeit
ist in Ordnung.
Jetzt, wo der Berg näherkommt,
wachsen die Zweifel,
ob die Idee wirklich so gut war,
am Ende meiner Russlandjahre
so hoch hinaus zu wollen.
* Sentimentale Gitarrenklänge *
Der Elbrus
befindet sich mitten im Kaukasus.
Er liegt zwischen
den beiden russischen Republiken
Kabardino-Balkarien
und Karatschai-Tscherkessien.
Und nahe an der Grenze zu Georgien.
* Bergführer Alexej
spricht russisch. *
Gehst du zu Fuss?
- Ja.
Das ist ein gutes Training. Ich will
schauen, wie es meinem Rücken geht.
Mein Körper
muss sich an die Höhe gewöhnen.
Der Plan: eine Woche Akklimatisation.
Sonst kann es gefährlich werden,
sagt mir Alexej.
Das Ziel des heutigen Tages
ist ein Seitental des Elbrus.
Allein es zu erreichen,
ist schon ein Abenteuer.
Nicht nur
wegen des museumsreifen Lifts,
sondern auch, weil es hier
an der Grenze zu Georgien
überall Spezialbewilligungen braucht.
Im Sommer 2008 haben Georgien und
Russland einen kurzen Krieg geführt.
Die Beziehungen
sind bis heute angespannt.
Ich höre hier aber auch sagen,
der Staatsmacht gehe es mehr darum,
die lokale muslimische Bevölkerung
zu überwachen, als um Grenzschutz.
* Dramatische Synthesizerklänge *
Filmen an den Checkpoints
ist verboten.
Die Kontrolle der diversen Papiere
wird genau genommen.
Nach einer langen Holperfahrt
kommen wir dann doch noch
im Bergsteigercamp Ullutau an.
Das Wichtigste ist, dass du
den Pass dabei hast. - Den Pass?
Das ist der wichtigste Teil
der Ausrüstung für Besuche hier.
Und wenn man ihn vergisst?
Gefängnis.
Alexej gibt mir heute Morgen eine
erste Lektion im Steigeisengehen.
Wir sind im Ullutau-Tal, im Winter
ein beliebtes Skitourengebiet.
Hier unten?
- Perfekt.
Genau so.
Steigeisen sind keine Schuhe.
Sie haben Zähne.
Steh immer etwas auseinander.
Auseinander?
Wenn du das nicht tust,
dann fällst du beim Gehen.
Immer: Abstand.
Nein, nein.
Siehst du, was du machst?
Diese Zähne hier.
- Ah.
So?
- Genau.
Alle Zähne müssen ins Eis.
Umgekehrt, so.
Umgekehrt, aha.
Schau, du machst das so.
Wenn du so machst,
dann rutschst du ab.
Du kannst dich nicht halten.
Du bist nicht stabil.
Nicht so hoch,
das ist ziemlich steil.
Bien.
Sehr gut.
Das ist wie in der ersten Klasse.
Die Leute, die sterben -
sind das Leute wie ich,
die das erste Mal hoch gehen?
Oder solche ohne Bergführer?
Die Mehrheit kommt ohne Bergführer.
Einige haben zwar etwas Erfahrung,
aber nicht für diese Höhe.
Es kommen viele Dinge zusammen:
das Wetter, dann die grosse Höhe.
Dein Kopf funktioniert nicht so gut
wie auf normaler Höhe.
Er sagt, dieses Jahr
habe es schon sechs Tote gegeben.
Gut so. Stopp! Jetzt wieder runter.
Es geht tipptopp. Wieder runter.
Horizontal, horizontal.
- D'accord.
Spalten, die Kälte,
Verirren im Nebel.
Das und die Höhenkrankheit
sind die Gründe,
warum der Elbrus den Menschen
zum Verhängnis werden kann,
erklärt mir Alexej.
Ich bin froh,
dass ich nach diesem Tag
bereits Vertrauen
in meinen Bergführer gefasst habe.
Ich würde nicht mit jedem
auf über 5'000 m steigen wollen.
* Vogelgezwitscher *
Wie geht es dir?
Gut, ich bin besonders froh,
dass es dem Rücken gut geht.
Und die Schuhe?
Sind in Ordnung.
Lass es uns so machen:
Wenn ich den Gipfel nicht schaffe,
zeigen wir diese Szene nicht.
Ein guter Tag.
- Ja, ein sehr guter.
Der Alkohol tut gut
nach der Anstrengung.
Es ist das Beste gegen Muskelkater.
Um die Muskeln zu reinigen.
Ich bin Chemiker,
ich kenne alle Geheimnisse.
Ich will betonen, dass das die
Empfehlung meines Bergführers ist.
Normalerweise
trinke ich nicht während der Arbeit.
Ich auch nicht.
Können wir filmen, wenn ihr kocht?
Oje! Uns filmen?
Wir sind doch nicht zurechtgemacht!
Aber bei euch
schmeckt alles immer so lecker.
Filmt nur,
wir sind ja schön.
Ja, schön seid ihr.
Und es schmeckt ausgezeichnet.
Was gibt es heute?
Plov gibt es.
- Plov?
Das ist bei uns ein Nationalgericht.
Typisch für hier?
Mit Fleisch.
Ich werde euch Plov servieren.
Wie ist es hier mit den Ausländern?
Gut.
Sind sie nett zu euch?
- Sie sind nett.
Alles ist in Ordnung.
Wir lieben Ausländer.
Ich arbeite seit 25 Jahren
mit Ausländern.
Wir verstehen uns gut, trotz
der unterschiedlichen Sprachen.
Wir verstehen uns
mit Händen und Füssen.
Alle fahren zufrieden wieder weg.
Hier schränkt niemand
den anderen ein.
Hier sind die Leute sehr offen und
schliessen schnell Freundschaften.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Wir haben die Unterkunft
trotz Hochsaison fast für uns allein.
Alexej liebt es, hier zu sein,
weil ihn der Ort an die Blütezeit
des russischen Bergsports erinnert.
Der Chemiker
gehörte in den 1980er-Jahren
zur Elite der sowjetischen Kletterer
und wurde vom Staat gefördert.
Jetzt führt er mich in das Camp.
Er möchte mir eine Bergsteigerlegende
aus alten Tagen vorstellen.
Vielleicht hat der Mann
ja einen Tipp für mich?
Guten Tag, Christof,
Schweizer Fernsehen. Sehr erfreut.
Ich habe schon viel
von Ihnen gehört.
Er hört nicht so gut.
- Ach so.
Sind Sie gerade auf dem Weg? Wohin?
Gehen wir doch
in den Ausbildungsraum.
Ja, gehen wir.
Beim Gang dorthin wird klar: Das Camp
hat seine besten Zeiten hinter sich.
Hier trainierten einst
Hunderte von Bergsportlern.
Die Gewerkschaft bezahlte.
Nach dem Ende der Sowjetunion
fiel die Unterstützung weg.
Heute könne sich nur noch wenige
den Aufenthalt hier leisten,
auch wenn die Preise bescheiden sind.
Und Putin hilft nicht?
Er ist doch selber Sportler.
Nein, nein.
Aber der Tourismus
wird jetzt doch gefördert?
Ja, aber für ihn gibt es nur
Fussball, die Olympischen Spiele
und jetzt noch die WM,
der Alpinismus zählt nicht viel.
Zum Glück haben wir den Elbrus,
da wollen alle rauf.
Das ist der höchste Punkt Europas.
Das ist meine Ehefrau.
Sehr erfreut.
- Hallo.
Sie ist auch Alpinistin,
nationale Meisterin.
Sie war UdSSR-Champion
im Bergsteigen, als sie jung war.
Sie hat viele Jahre hier gearbeitet,
als Ausbildnerin und Leiterin.
Arbeiten Sie noch?
Ich helfe ihm.
- Sie hilft mir.
Die Liebe zu den Bergen
hat die beiden
vor 63 Jahren zusammengebracht.
Seit 50 Jahren wohnen sie im Sommer
in diesem Bergsteigercamp.
Die Liebe der Russen zum Elbrus
ist noch wesentlich älter
und hat eine bewegte Geschichte.
1935: Eine Gruppe Soldaten besteigt
den Elbrus und verkabelt den Berg.
In den Niederungen des Flachlands
warten die Leute gespannt
auf Nachrichten vom Gipfel.
* Fanfarenklänge *
Die junge Sowjetunion feiert
ihren technischen Fortschritt.
* Jubelrufe *
Auch Lenin darf posthum
an der Freude teilhaben.
(Originalkommentar)
Hier unsere Gebirgsjäger
auf dem Marsch ins Elbrusgebiet.
Dass der Elbrus Symbol
von Russlands Macht und Stärke ist,
bleibt auch den Nationalsozialisten
nicht verborgen.
(Originalkommentar)
Eine Kompanie ausgewählter Soldaten
einer schwäbisch-bayerischen
Gebirgsdivision
hat es sich zur Aufgabe gemacht,
auf dem Gipfel
dieses 5'630 m hohen Bergriesen
die Reichskriegsflagge zu setzen.
All diese Soldaten
sind hervorragende Bergsteiger.
Weite Gletscher und Schneefelder
müssen bei schneidender Kälte
überwunden werden.
Im Sommer 1942 gelingt es
der Wehrmacht, den Berg zu erobern.
(Originalkommentar) Der Elbrus
ist bezwungen. Unsere Gebirgsjäger
vollbrachten eine kämpferische
und alpinistische Grosstat.
* Schüsse *
Nur wenige Monate später:
die Rückeroberung durch die Sowjets.
Der Kampf in grosser Höher
fordert viele Opfer.
Aber er stellt ein wichtiges Stück
nationaler Ehre wieder her.
* Dramatische Geigenklänge *
Nach dem Krieg geht es am Elbrus
wesentlich friedlicher zu,
aber nun wird der Berg
definitiv zum Nationalheiligtum.
1967, zum 50. Jahrestag
der Oktoberrevolution,
sollen es gar 2'500 Menschen
gewesen sein, die am Gipfel standen.
Am selben Tag.
Gleichzeitig
nimmt der Massentourismus Fahrt auf.
Bahnen, Hotels und Bergunterkünfte
werden gebaut.
Von überall aus dem Ostblock
strömen die Menschen her.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Was empfehlen Sie mir?
Ich will am Freitag mit Alexej
da hoch - zum ersten Mal.
Es braucht
eine gute Akklimatisation.
Sie müssen auf über 4'000 m gehen:
ein bisschen trainieren, atmen.
Auf den Elbrus muss man
rauf und runter, rauf und runter.
Alles an einem Stück zu machen,
ist sehr schwierig.
Erlauben Sie mir, Ihnen im Namen
unseres Ausbildungszentrums Ullutau
dieses Abzeichen zu verleihen.
Es heisst Alpinist Russlands.
Vielen Dank.
Wir machen es hier fest.
Danke,
das ist eine echte Motivation.
Darauf müssen wir einen Tee trinken.
Beim Tee handelt sich dann
um einen 50%igen - selbstgebrannt.
Dafür mit einem Toast.
Danke, dass ihr
ins Tal Adyr-Su gekommen seid,
in unser Berglager Ullutau.
Wir haben herrliche Berge.
Ich hoffe sehr,
dass es euch hier gefällt,
und dass ihr mit Freunden
hierher zurückkommen werdet.
Wir werden euch immer empfangen.
Danke.
Ich werde meine Kinder mitnehmen.
Ist das auch wirklich gut
für den Elbrus?
Das schadet nicht.
Zu Fuss hoch und Kopf voran runter.
Ein bisschen darf man schon,
es erweitert die Blutgefässe.
Es erweitere die Blutgefässe,
sagt sie.
Aha, etwas Gesundes.
Etwas, das hilft.
Wir sind in Terskol,
dem Zentrum des Elbrus-Tourismus.
Bei mir zu Hause in den Walliser
Alpen wäre das quasi Zermatt.
Die alten Sowjetbauten
fallen mir als erstes ins Auge.
Dann sind da aber auch unübersehbar
die Zeichen von Aufschwung.
Auch die Moschee ist neu.
Was ebenfalls auffällt,
ist auch hier die Militärpräsenz.
Mein nächster
Akklimatisierungsschritt steht an.
Heute geht es auf 3'000 m.
Und ich werde den Elbrus
so nahe sehen wie noch nie.
Du kannst dich umdrehen.
Oh! Das gibt's doch nicht!
Dort hinauf müssen wir?
Dort hinauf müssen wir.
Weit.
- Und hoch.
Weit und hoch.
Das schaffen wir.
- Ja, das schaffen wir.
Schön. Toll, nicht wahr?
Da krieg ich gleich Herzklopfen.
Mein Ziel heute ist der Berg Cheget,
auf den
eine altehrwürdige Bahn fährt.
Das selbe Ziel haben auch
diese Grenzschutzsoldaten.
Nur fahren sie nicht
zur Akklimatisierung rauf wie ich.
Vor wenigen Jahren
gab es Anschläge in Terskol.
Die Täter waren Islamisten,
behauptet Moskau.
Hier munkelt man,
es war eine Abrechnung
mit der lokalen Bevölkerung,
mit den Balkaren.
Aufgeklärt wurden die Fälle nie.
Eine Reisewarnung
besteht jedenfalls noch immer.
Ich möchte vom Bahnchef wissen,
wie sicher die Lage ist.
Sind Sie Ruslan?
Ja, hallo.
Wie geht's?
- Gut.
Wir sind hier ja im nördlichen
Kaukasus, ein heisses Gebiet.
Sind die Leute eingeschüchtert,
wenn sie hierher fahren?
Die einen fürchten sich,
andere haben keine Angst.
Im Grunde ist hier nichts los.
Alle wollen nur Gutes.
Aber es gab hier 2011
ja einige Terroranschläge.
War danach noch etwas?
Nein, seither war nichts.
Die Region um den Elbrus
ist politisch hochkomplex.
Das wird mir auf dieser Reise
einmal mehr bewusst.
Schön hier.
Wie hoch sind wir? 3'000 m ü.M.?
Aber der läuft ja noch gar nicht.
Aha, es geht noch weiter.
- Ja.
Ich gehe mal nachfragen.
Ich habe früher als Schüler
beim uns im Dorf jeweils
bei den Seilbahnen ausgeholfen.
Jetzt fühlt es sich bei diesem
Gefährt aus den 60er-Jahren an,
als würde mich
die Vergangenheit einholen.
* Lautes Surren *
Wie heissen Sie?
- Ich bin Rasul.
Und der Lift funktioniert?
- Ja, er funktioniert.
Was hat der Lift für ein Baujahr?
- 1967.
Ist es nicht gefährlich?
In den 50 Jahren
ist nie etwas vorgefallen.
Wie lange
arbeiten Sie denn schon hier?
Seit 1978.
- 1978?
Ich war zwei Jahre in der Armee.
Danach kam ich zurück
und seither arbeite ich hier.
Können wir dabei sein, wenn Sie
die Bahn einschalten? - Natürlich.
Nimmst du auf?
Lisa, wir müssen uns beeilen.
Er sagt, der Geheimdienst
warte schon. Er ist etwas nervös.
Gleich fahren wir los.
* Klingeln *
Gestern hat mir im Dorf
eine Frau gesagt,
die Balkaren würden sich
nicht entwickeln wollen. Stimmt das?
Nein, das stimmt so nicht.
Wir möchten uns entwickeln.
Aber wir wollen selbst investieren,
den Service noch besser machen.
Die Gastfreundschaft
liegt uns im Blut.
Das wollen wir bewahren.
Das ist kaukasisch, nicht?
Ja, das ist unsere Tradition.
Aber wenn jemand von aussen mit Geld
kommt und hier alles kaufen will,
würden die balkarischen Sitten
und Traditionen verschwinden
und auch die Gastfreundschaft,
die wir noch sehr pflegen.
* Entspannte Klänge *
Hast du keine Angst auf diesem Lift?
Nein, aber der Elbrus
macht mir Sorgen.
Er wird immer höher,
je höher wir fahren.
Das wird ein Krampf.
Das kann ich dir jetzt schon sagen.
In den Bergen zählen Kameradschaft
und Vertrauen, hört man immer.
Aber hier oben
gibt es kein Entrinnen
vor der Kontrolle
durch die Beamten des Geheimdienstes.
Doch jetzt will ich mich
darauf konzentrieren,
was Alexej mir zum richtigen Atmen
in der Höhe zu sagen hat.
Der Rhythmus beim Gehen ist wichtig.
Auf dieser Höhe
muss man zweimal so häufig atmen
wie man eigentlich möchte.
Wir laufen ja so.
* Er atmet stossweise. *
Tief einatmen?
Es ist wichtig,
eben nicht tief einzuatmen,
weil der Hals sonst austrocknet.
V.a. wenn es kalt ist,
kann man sich sonst erkälten.
Und dann erstickst du vom Husten.
Es hilft auf dieser Höhe,
wie ein Hund zu atmen.
Mit jedem Schritt ein und aus.
* Er atmet stossweise. *
Und auf 4'500-5'000 m atmen wir so.
* Er atmet schneller. *
Um den Rhythmus zu finden,
ist Singen gut.
* Alexej summt eine Melodie. *
Das ist ein guter Platz hier.
Scheint wie für uns gemacht.
Es gibt ja seit Langem
diesen Streit:
Befindet sich der Elbrus
nun in Asien oder Europa?
Nun, das ist schwer zu sagen.
Geologisch, soweit ich das verstehe,
ich bin kein Spezialist,
ist der Elbrus eindeutig in Europa.
Hier treffen sich die europäische
und die asiatische Platte.
Der Elbrus befindet sich
15 km nördlich des Hauptkamms.
D.h.,
er befindet sich ganz in Europa.
Aber wenn jemand damit politische
Probleme hat - mir ist es egal.
Der Elbrus ist der Elbrus
und genügt sich selbst.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich raufgehe,
wühlt es mich auf.
Ah, interessant.
Bis jetzt sah ich den Elbrus
nur aus der Distanz.
Aber heute wage ich mich
direkt an seine Flanken.
Mein nächster
Akklimatisierungsschritt steht an.
Aber anders als im Norden
bringt uns vom Süden her
die Bahn bis auf 3'500 m.
Meine Route ist
die meistbegangene und einfachste -
wie gemacht für Anfänger wie mich.
Christof, schau mal!
Sag mir, was du siehst.
4'000.
Warst du häufig auf 4'000 m?
- Nein.
Gratuliere.
- Danke.
4'000, nicht schlecht.
- Lass uns umdrehen.
Nein, nein.
Allerdings habe ich mir
die Aussicht auf 4'000 m
etwas anders vorgestellt.
Darf ich euch etwas fragen?
Woher seid ihr?
Aus St. Petersburg.
Wollt ihr da hoch?
Ja, das haben wir vor.
In diesem Outfit?
- Ja, klar.
Ernsthaft?
- Ja, ernsthaft.
Wann geht ihr denn?
Wir versuchen es morgen.
Wir waren schon auf über 3'000 m.
Wir hatten ein Training.
Und jetzt der Elbrus.
Seid ihr richtige Alpinistinnen?
Wir sind Anfängerinnen.
Aber vielversprechende.
Vorsicht, Vorsicht!
Auch das habe ich nicht erwartet.
Eine der Gefahren am Elbrus:
Man kann überfahren werden.
Die Pistenfahrzeuge und Schneemobile
fahren mit den Touristen und Berg-
steigern bis auf über 4'500 m hoch.
Ich aber
akklimatisiere mich zu Fuss weiter
und treffe auf Gipfelstürmer
beim Abstieg.
Waren Sie oben?
- Ja, heute hat es geklappt.
Allein?
- Mit einem Bergführer natürlich.
Ist es schwierig?
Dieses Mal war es etwas einfacher
als vor sieben Jahren.
Ich hab's damals geschafft,
aber ich weiss nicht mehr, wie.
Man hat mich runtergetragen.
Jetzt bin rauf gekommen.
Aber es gab einen Moment,
da war ich bewusstlos.
Ernsthaft?
Ja, und mir war schlecht.
Nach 2 Sek. Knock-out
bin ich wieder aufgestanden.
Da oben, nach dem Sattel.
Es war wie im Ring:
nach 2 Sek. ausgeknockt.
Aber dann habe ich
den Kampf fortgesetzt.
Angezählt, aber nicht K.o.
Nein, heute kein K.o.
Einerseits Bewusstlose und Tote -
andererseits der Berg als Halligalli.
Ich fühle mich hin- und hergerissen.
Ich war auf 4'600 m.
Meine Akklimatisierung
ist abgeschlossen.
Jetzt ziehen wir ins Hochlager um.
Alles Gepäck muss rauf.
Auf dem Weg erfahre ich
eine weitere jener Geschichten,
die nur der Elbrus
hervorbringen kann.
Trainiert ihr hier?
Das ist ein Suchtrupp.
Was sucht ihr?
Hier waren während des Krieges
Bergtruppen, sog. Edelweisser.
Ah, ihr sucht Leichen.
Ja, Überreste.
Wirklich?
Lässt sich etwas finden?
Wir finden immer Tote.
Tote Soldaten?
Bei uns in der Schweiz
haben wir dasselbe,
aber keine Soldaten,
sondern eher ...
Alpinisten? Ja, die finden wir auch.
Und wen findet ihr aus dem Krieg?
Deutsche?
Wir finden Deutsche
wie auch unsere Leute.
Das Hochlager liegt auf 3'700 m Höhe.
Mit schwerem Gepäck ist die Luft
da oben noch dünner als eh schon.
Komm, mach mal Pause, komm!
Hopp!
Oh, dieser Wind!
* Christof lacht. *
Wo sind denn die Leute?
* Alexej spricht russisch. *
Das ist mehr Büchsenzauber
als Hüttenzauber, oder?
Na, das geht schon!
Das Damenabteil.
Schau mal hier!
Das wäre also die Küche.
Oh! Ob das gut ist
für meinen lädierten Rücken?
Na, ich weiss nicht.
Es ist etwas ...
Ist es zu hart?
Aber ja. Das kommt schon gut.
Daran glauben und kämpfen.
Ich bin froh, wenn es losgeht.
Der Ort ist nicht gerade der,
wo man lange Ferien machen möchte.
Aber dann spielt uns das Wetter
einen Streich.
An eine Besteigung
ist im Moment nicht zu denken.
Ich muss lernen,
dass Höhenbergsteigen
zu einem beträchtlichen Teil
aus Warten besteht.
* Sentimentale Gitarrenklänge *
Wir schauen, wann wir gehen können.
Am Samstag ist der Wind schwächer.
25, am Freitag 45 km/h.
Auf dem Gipfel?
- Ja.
"Aufzeichnungen aus dem Totenhaus".
Ui, Dostojewski.
Es gibt nur vier Bücher
in der Bibliothek.
Ich dachte, etwas über den Elbrus
wäre dabei, aber da war nichts.
Sich bewegen ist jedoch
immer noch besser als Herumliegen.
Aber der Hochgebirgsverkehr,
die Ungewissheit und das Warten
drücken auf die Stimmung.
Ja, diese Pistenraupen
und Snowmobile den ganzen Tag,
aber vielleicht brauchen wir sie
dann selber auch noch.
Ich glaube, den wahren Elbrus
entdeckt man erst auf dem Gipfel.
Wie stellst du dir
den wahren Elbrus vor?
Ich hoffe wenigstens
auf etwas Stille,
und auf etwas
Geheimnisvolles und ... Erhabenes.
Davon bekommt man hier
nicht so viel mit.
Aber wenn man dann mal oben ist -
es ist das Dach von Europa,
von Russland.
Ich würde mich schon freuen,
mal da oben zu sein.
Ich frage mich zwar,
ob's mich hier braucht.
Nicht? Du siehst die Massen
und fragst dich:
"Braucht es mich
wirklich auch noch?"
Dann endlich:
der Abend vor dem Gipfelversuch.
Und die Entscheidung:
Pistenfahrzeug - ja oder nein?
Alexej sorgt sich um meine Kräfte
und er hat noch andere Argumente.
Diese Fahrzeuge sind nun mal hier.
Wenn wir daneben gehen,
atmen wir nur das Benzin ein
und vergiften uns.
Ich wäre dagegen,
die Pistenraupe extra zu rufen.
Aber sie fahren eh hin und her.
Natürlich gibt es
die ethische Frage,
v.a. von der Südseite her,
wir fahren
mit dem Auto und der Bahn her.
Also: dieses Mal mit Pistenfahrzeug,
nächstes Mal die Nordroute.
Oder von Westen.
- Abgemacht.
* Motorenlärm *
Um 3 Uhr in der Früh geht's los.
Was geht dir durch den Kopf?
- Was sagst du?
Ja, ich freue mich.
Gut, dass es endlich losgeht.
Ich habe zwar nicht gedacht,
dass wir heute noch gehen.
Vor 3-4 Std. hat es geblitzt und
geregnet, dann sogar noch geschneit.
Aber jetzt wagen wir es.
* Dramatische Klänge
über Motorenlärm *
Die ersten paar 100 m waren einfach.
- Ja.
Das Gewissen plagt mich schon etwas,
ehrlich gesagt.
Aber von jetzt an
sind wir alle gleich.
* Sturmwind *
Okay, lasst uns losgehen.
Christof!
- Gehen wir!
So ganz berauschend dünkt mich
das Wetter immer noch nicht,
doch der Wind soll
im Lauf des Morgens nachlassen.
Das beruhigt mich,
denn es liegen trotz Pistenfahrzeug
1'000 Höhenmeter vor mir.
Im Morgengrauen ist es am kältesten,
Alexey schätzt es auf -15 °C.
* Schwebende Gitarrenklänge *
Wie findest du es?
Schön. Ich halte mich
an die Tipps von Alexej. Das hilft.
Atmen. Was hat er gesagt?
"Mehr atmen als man will."
Christof! Gratuliere! 5'000!
Danke.
Eben: Mehr atmen, als man will und
bei jedem Schritt eine Pause machen.
Und im Innern immer ein Lied singen.
* Christof summt
das Volkslied "Bergvagabunden". *
* Majestätische Klänge *
* Keuchen *
Ist dort der Gipfel?
Das ist der Vorgipfel.
Der Gipfel ist dahinter. - Aha.
Ist das der Gipfel?
Da hinten.
Strengt's an?
Es geht, aber langsam schon etwas.
Wie geht's dem Rücken?
- Gut.
Es geht alles gut, wirklich alles.
Ich habe sogar
tiefe philosophische Erkenntnisse.
Und die sind?
- Das kann ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Das muss ich erst verarbeiten.
- Ach, komm schon!
Nein, es ist wirklich fantastisch:
Du gehst und denkst.
Und gehst.
* Kurzatmiges Keuchen *
* Schwebende Klavierklänge *
Keine Fragen, Lisa. Ist gut?
Du hängst etwas durch.
- Keine Fragen.
Wieso keine Fragen?
Das stresst mich noch mehr
als die dünne Luft.
* Dramatische Klänge *
Nach 6 Std.
ist der Gipfel endlich in Reichweite.
* Erhabene Klänge *
Der Gipfel. Geh! Ich weiss nicht,
wie man zum Gipfel geht.
Das ist der Gipfel?
- Ich bin hinter dir.
Congratulations!
- Alexej Borisowitsch, spasiba.
Spasiba.
- Spasiba.
Gery, super Arbeit!
Spasiba.
Jetzt kann ich nichts sagen.
Lisa, jetzt musst du nichts fragen.
Das war eigentlich einmal
als Abschluss gedacht.
Ich war vor 25 Jahren
das erste Mal in Russland,
dann zehn Jahre als Korrespondent.
Es ist wahnsinnig viel passiert,
viel Trauriges und viel Schönes.
Und ich dachte mir: Ich komme
hierher, um das abzuschliessen.
Komme hier hoch, sage Gott
oder dem Schicksal Danke
und schliesse das ab.
Und während des Laufens
hatte ich den Gedanken,
dass das einfach
die leichte Variante ist.
Die ganze Zeit hatte ich das Gefühl,
ich müsse nochmals zurückkommen.
Ich muss das von Norden her machen,
ohne Seilbahn und Pistenfahrzeug.
Und vielleicht
ist das auch ein Omen,
dass ich gar nicht abschliessen muss
mit Russland.
Ja, dass es vielleicht
eine neue Aufgabe gibt.
Und das hat mich völlig gepackt.
Das finde ich völlig schön.
Du denkst, du gehst etwas wandern,
gehst mal in die Berge.
Und hast plötzlich
ganz neue Gedanken.
Ja.
Aber das schneidest du dann raus.
* Schwebende Geigenklänge *